I just want to say it's been so nice to
get out of the city with you camping in
nature I feel like you're who you really
are
away from work what are you thinking hey
guys I'm Brent rose writer and glam
counselor and today we're going through
some of my favorite camping gear now
this is not your ultralight backpacking
setup this is for when you've got plenty
of space in your car weight is not a
concern and you and your friends want
your camp to be as baller as possible
let's get to the fun stuff this is the
shift pod
it's a reflective dust proof popup dome
tent and it's great for everything from
Burning Man to the High Sierra it's also
super easy to set up now I've only done
this once before but I'm me
[Music]
come on in the center you have seven
feet of headroom there are six mesh
windows with zipper bowl covers there
are ports for ventilation and power
cords and if you really want to take
things to the next level you can add
some of shift pods color-changing
remote-controlled lights baller you
could sleep a whole family in here or
start a whole family in here this is the
exped mega Matt duo ten it's the most
ridiculously absurdly comfortable
camping pad you can possibly get you'd
be happy to sleep on it at home it has
four inches of cushy foam padding plus
the air you put into it with the
schnozzle pump bag which great name
[Music]
unless you're the princess and the pea
you could be sleeping on a boulder and
you wouldn't even notice but if you've
got a mattress built for two
you want a sleeping bag to match enter
the queen-size Sierra Designs front
country bed - this gigantic sleeping bag
is big enough for two people to sleep in
any position they want it's also zipper
list and it'll keep you warm down to 27
degrees Fahrenheit we can attach
directly to your mattress and it even
has an escape hatch for your feet and
they get a little too toasty
so let's talk about power this is the
goal zero yeti 400 solar generator kit
includes a 33 amp hour battery and a
built in inverter that means it can run
AC and DC and it even has USB plugs
built in it's attached to two foldable
20 watt panels which is keeping it nice
and juicy and that's important for
powering this little beauty this is a
DIY evaporative swamp cooler it was
about a hundred bucks from a guy on Etsy
it's basically just a cooler with a
couple holes drilled out and a fan built
in you just fill it with water and our
ice and the fans circulates it so when
it's hot and dry it keeps this place
nice and cool another cool way to get
power this is the bio light camp stove -
basically it burns twigs and small
pieces of wood and uses the heat
exchange to power this external battery
that in turn can be used to power your
phone and small cameras you can simply
pop a pot on top and boil some water or
you can use this slick grill and do some
backcountry barbecue it even has a USB
light so you can see what you're cooking
but how about when you want to keep
things cool
this is the Orca cooler 26 it's made of
super durable roto molded plastic if you
add a couple padlocks it's actually bear
proof it has an excellent drain really
nice handles and best of all it'll keep
your ice icy in warm weather for up to
eight days now that it's getting cold
it's time for my favorite jacket this is
the Eddie Bauer first ascent ever
thermally it's the first ever outdoor
jacket to use the thin down technology
you know how most down jackets have
baffles to keep the feathers in place
which leave you looking kind of like a
skinny Michelin Man well thin down is
the first one that eliminates the need
for baffles basically the down is
actually adhered to the layers of fabric
which keeps it from shifting around not
only does that make this jacket 30%
lighter but because it doesn't have
baffles it eliminates cold spots making
it ten percent warmer - this thing is so
comfy last and certainly not least is
the Garmin inReach Explorer plus when
you're way off the grid this thing is
your tether to the outside world and
potentially your lifeline it is built-in
topographic maps with GPS weather and it
allows you to share your location with
friends and family so they can see where
you are in your adventure it'll even
allow you to send and receive text
messages through the device itself or
through a paired smartphone and most
importantly if you hit this SOS button
it'll send in search-and-rescue no
matter where you are so those are just a
few of my favorite high-end car camping
items but what are yours let me know in
the comments below subscribe to wire it
if you haven't already with all that
being said there's really only one thing
left to do
Oh Betty Oh your breath the harsh